now your eyes aren't playing tricks on
you the thumbnail of this video it's
real it actually happened because this
movie made me a [ __ ] [ __ ] let's just
review it quicker we do it the quicker I
don't have to think about it anymore
[Music]
fifty shake good luck the fifty shades
darker is the shitty sequel to the
shitty Fifty Shades of Grey movies in
this movie Christian and Anna it's their
names [ __ ] weird that I know that
we're not dating anymore because the
last movie they're not dating and then
they've run into each other and she's
like yeah sure I'll take you back was
bang which makes her the biggest
cinematic idiot ever maybe it's the
biggest literary idiot ever but that
would imply that the book is literature
rather than toilet paper is what it is
this guy exhibits all the serial killer
as tendencies he ever did in the first
one he stalks her he's creepy he's
controlling not in like an endearing way
no he's like joke I says no words matter
dating again
I just the movies about the movies about
them dating has to be because the movies
not about anything else I really mean
that this mostly at a point I was like
it's still happening his movies still
going on the movie it's just right about
two hours long on the nose it feels like
three and that's a problem because this
entire movie is on the shoulders of the
relationship of the two people you do
not give a [ __ ] about nor do you care
about their relationship what are they
doing they're dating do you like them no
I don't like them as people nor do I
like the relationship because the
relationship is dumb as [ __ ] there's
nothing enjoyable about it then they say
ridiculous ass things like they just
[ __ ] a couple times and she's like I
love you guys that's up mmm you guys
just went there it's been three days and
then things happen throughout the movie
that don't actually affect the movie at
all like you saw in the trailer that
girl just shows up and creeps her out
you know the girl that looks like the
girl from rings that happens she shows
up like once and then twice and then
that's over did it do anything about it
there's nothing just happen right down
why's this happens in the movie I swear
to god I'm not even making this up
he has to go in his helicopter and go in
a meeting somewhere in Portland Oregon
so he gets into his helicopter he's
flying the helicopter goes down he's
missing for about two minutes it's on
the news and she's like oh my gosh and
her friends are like we'll find him I
swear then the news is like hey he's
been found and that moment he walks in
like hey what a mess and it did nothing
nothing for the plot it did nothing for
the movie did nothing for the story did
nothing for the
character it had any gracious bone in
their body whatsoever they would have
cut that part out made the movie about
five minutes shorter I'll take all I can
get five minutes with him in the world a
minute then there's this great boss that
she has and this dude goes from zero to
creepy in no time when he blocked her
the door is like how does he [ __ ] you
how you want like I'm okay it's so
cartoony and that would stand out more I
almost forgot to talk about it would
stand out more if everyone in this movie
wasn't cartoony everyone is it's almost
like somebody wrote Twilight fan fiction
on their blackberry would that's exactly
how this should happen this movies
actually I'm not even joking around with
you because I mean I want to be
objective or go to this movie when it
was starting and I was like okay be
objective don't just say it's dog [ __ ]
because you wanted to be dog [ __ ] see
the truth see the movie for what it is
[ __ ] worse than I thought of a bit
I'm not even joking you it is horrendous
watching this movie is like getting
ass-raped with katana sword yeah from
Suicide Squad because it is painful in
ways you don't even want to think about
and it steals a part of your soul the
movies literally the plot is these
people just date and [ __ ] and by [ __ ] I
mean not even interesting [ __ ] my mom my
mom watches my videos so that's awkward
not once again we have some nice
lovemaking and such once again fifty
shades darker is like fifty shades of
gray in that it's like the blockbuster
days on the top shelf of Blockbuster
Video you have those rated-r porn they
didn't show you the goods but at least
those ones attempted to make a plot if
you change darker it's like those top
shelf blockbuster movies with less of a
plot and less sex acting is about on par
though I got home I was turning on my
lights here to do my video sitting on
the camera I felt like I was setting up
a kill room in Dexter let's just murder
this thing get it over with
you knew it was going to happen I knew
it was going to happen when I got out of
it somewhere when I sat down in the
movie theater to watch this movie
Agatha's a Precog was like she knew guys
in the end this movie was painful I
wasn't just ridiculous and nonsensical
it was boring his [ __ ] it was humorous
when it tried to be serious and boring
when it tried to be sexy I walked out of
here truly Babel the only fun part is
talking [ __ ] when we all walked out of
the movie everybody pull the studio cups
around we're all just talking mad [ __ ]
about the movie were like they know ya
fifty shades darker is not just dog [ __ ]
it's dog [ __ ]
squared you have to
very enjoyable movies opening the
theaters this weekend neither of which
is fifty shades darker come on do a
solid stop these things from a banner
alright guys so fifty shades darker
don't see it ever so like a movie have
you seen it yet what did you think about
it with John wick - how rad was that
whatever you think of those comment
below let me know you want an applicable
movie what's the most belong boring
drawn-out ass painfully shitty movie
you've seen lately whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to stay more
[Music]